lo primero que hay que decir es que el
gobierno tiene veinticuatro años
ininterrumpidos de ejercicio
gubernamental razón por la cual es muy
difícil
creer que ellos no sabían lo que estaba
pasando al interior de su gobierno las
personas que han sido capturadas forman
parte de la de los bandos para no decir
las bandas que dentro del mismo gobierno
compiten por la riqueza material y por
el poder político es muy extraño lo que
está ocurriendo sin que haya sin que se
haya sabido desde las altas esferas del
gobierno habida cuenta de que ellos
controlan todas las instituciones
incluyendo la asamblea nacional que
debería ser el contrapoder al ejecutivo
la contraloría general de la república
un militante que sus filas la fiscalía
general u otro militante de sus filas
así como el defensor del pueblo esto es
una trama mafiosa entre los propios
miembros del gobierno y además suma eso
el hecho de que lo hacen Porque pueden
hacerlo no tienen contención en la
sociedad habida cuenta de que la
oposición por su abstención dejar
regalado sistemáticamente todas las
instituciones
bueno anuncia el ejecutivo de maduro un
total de 42 capturas qué credibilidad
tiene esa investigación dentro del país
y en el exterior bueno en el exterior ha
causado un gran revuelo porque la gente
cree que en Venezuela las cosas marchan
de manera normal y no es verdad en
Venezuela es normal que eso ocurra
repito porque el gobierno lo hace porque
puede hacerlo y ellos lo conocen lo que
pasa es que detrás de esta trama de
corrupción ciertamente también hay otra
trama que aspira la sucesión de maduro
en el poder político y eso es lo que
están cobrando es que acaso ellos no
sabían que antes que todas estas estaba
vinculada con hechos de corrupción Claro
que lo sabían
Bueno usted ya lo estaba mencionando
pero se le pregunto más puntualmente
esta iniciativa del gobierno puede
relacionarse con que se acerca año
electoral evidentemente Ellos están
jugando a luchar internamente y hacia el
exterior para lavarse la cara diciendo
que el gobierno de maduro es un gran
luchador contra la corrupción cosa que
no es cierto porque luego de 24 años de
ejercicio ininterrumpido del poder y
haber desangrado al país económico y
financieramente aparte de los daños que
han causado en todo sentido desde el
punto de vista ambiental e institucional
entre otros no le van a decir a uno que
ellos no sabían lo que estaba pasando
esto para lavarse la cara frente a los
incautos que hay en Venezuela todavía y
también frente al mundo exterior porque
ahora les conviene mantener buenas
relaciones con buena parte de occidente
como una parte del hemisferio occidental